aujourd'hui je vais faire une tourte aux
champignons
alors pour faire la tourte champignons
que vous allez faire fils père en même
temps que moi déjà je met une petite
musique chaque jour vous savez je mets
une petite musique un pour eux voilà
pour égayer la cuisine vous dis faites
la cuisine en chanson moi c'est toujours
bon voilà donc là tu choisi cette
chanson c'est billy ze kick et les
gamins en folie voilà billy ze kick et
c'est ça tout le monde connaît ça c'est
réglé c'est sympa un moyen de locomotion
[Musique]
à la cambrousse
voilà bon alors les séries ont regardé
ce que je ferme la porte aux champignons
elle est là donc si vous leur photo
sachez le au moins là mais une comme ça
voilà qu'on a déposé devant ma porte
il ya quand même une tourte cas sonner à
la porte voilà hélas les chéris j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut pour faire la peau
alors la tourte qu'est ce qu'il vous
faut
et au fond de pâte feuilletée faut
savoir je savais même pas ce que c'était
une tourte aux champignons avons décidé
de la ferme je vous dis tout de suite un
g10 tourte aux champignons j'aurais très
bien pu dire hachis parmentier ou
conquête je sais même pas ce que j ai
donc pêché rick donc petit autres
champignons il faut te pattes
hier pour la plupart font la fine et la
3e phase tôt à faire ce qu'on appelle
une chèque sous kde merguez voilà donc
voilà on va faire comme ça ça veut dire
que les deux pas vont s'embrasser comme
comme ça on a des gars tort
on y pogo ton connaissait hippo glouton
voilà quand ça va mal matin bon ok j'ai
donc deux pas de feuilleter bien 750
grammes de champignons des bois
ils viennent des bois cela olic fat
chasse aux oies champignons des bois
sont ils sont plus tu vois c'est pas
comme les champignons paris qui se la
raconte le champignon de paris
ouais je palpe home shopping
et tout ça ouais
ouais tu la date on the way
le champion des bois et les cool tu vois
je prends là tu vois je suis pas un
salut tu as tu écoutes on va te tutoyer
coude il ya venons voilà il aime la vie
donc ça c'est bon on a besoin les chéris
de 20 centimes de crème fraîche commence
à voir la crème regarder et là une crème
c'est une crème qui est fraîche salaires
et fraîche en toutes circonstances elle
se réveiller les fraîches elle s'endort
à et fraîche les belles allées bien dans
sa tête elle va bien avec le champignon
des oies ils sont cool tu vois pas les
vrais choix très belle et très près
choix tout le contraire de moi je suis
rhin sur a6 alors j'ai encore mis des
crèmes qui n'en parlerai tout à l'heure
des cherry on a une cuillère à soupe
d'huile d'olive
voilà ça c'est pas que hier à se laisser
l'huile d'olive du d'olive ça fait
toujours beau gosse en faut toujours bon
en ce week end
gousse d'ail hugo boss j'adore ce mot la
mousse mousse et j'aime tagging cette
eau est belle est un beau soleil oui on
connaît mais leurs hôtes amoussou la
haye
howie vienne docomo est à bout cela eh
oui bah qu'il faut prendre l'accent non
quelques branches de persil j'ai mis là
dedans le père s'il faut faire quand la
tension je me suis lavé les mains
j'ai des vaches peux te dire tu peux y
aller mais le monsieur propre mais bien
devant moi il ferme sa gueule et à lire
il sent ça monsieur propre et bien de
vent marin il dira pas plus simple je
pus là donc merci merci voilà merci
merci faut toujours le coin comme ça le
persil plat comme as voilà d'ailleurs en
parlant de tercis à mon âge à la fin du
cours en un virus
on a tous avoir le persil qui sort du
cabba enfin je vous dis ça je dis rien
on a un jeune de talent c'est très
simple jeu de merde et qu'on sait rien
c'est rien s'inquiète passé et sont
inquiètes therrien s'est attaquée pour
ça je vais rattraper
bon ça c'est un sas et rien à maria
riesch est une technique pour casser les
deux y arrive et assurer la riveraine
qui sait faire ça qui sait faire à ce
qui s'est fait rare
ça fait du bien quand ça s'arrête à
cette merde bon voilà mais voilà aulas
malheureux avait il ya un peu de blanc
languedoc
j'en ai un peu j'en ai aimés au tarif
stayen bon voilà béchir y voilà donc
très bien donc là j'enlève le blanc
voilà mes chéris donc là j'ai un jaune
d'oeuf
tout ça c'est rien tout est propre tout
est oublié
alors ensuite parle pas on parle on
parle on va où il faut du sel et du
poivre
comme partout ça vous savez faire bon on
va démarrer
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
rincer et effeuillez le persil sel ce
n'est déjà fait voilà et peluches et
l'ail et hachez le sa gelée déjà fait
parce que si je devais faire ça en
direct
on était là jusqu'à 22 heures contes bon
voilà et c'est chez lui avec un torchon
propre
voilà un torchon voilà le torchon à
merveille des sahwa qui piquent mans
c'est pas le grand exemple quoi voilà
c'est pas le bon exemple
voilà ça c'est la connerie ça bon c'est
pas grave 2couper des champignons en
morceaux
faites chauffer l'huile d'olive dans une
poêle et faites y revenir les
champignons et de l'ail du sel et du
poivre à feu moyen durant dix minutes ça
aussi
j'ai demandé à quelqu'un de me le faire
faire dire la vérité il n'a ramené le
plat là et puis voilà je suis dis merci
et voilà merci monsieur terminée voilà
bon ensuite faux préchauffer le four
mois et a plein de trucs affaires
internes tête comme ça après la recette
n'a qu'une envie c'est de dormir pendant
deux ans donc là tu préchauffer le four
à 180° voile alors voilà il faut que je
le fasse parce que hier il ya plein de
gens qui ont dit oui il sait pas servir
d'un four
ouais un champignon pas ils étaient les
gars tu m'as sur twitter ouais ouais
ouais ouais pourquoi il sait pas se
servir de son propre fonds s'ébroue quoi
tu crois vraiment que c'est la première
fois que j'ai je te dis que c'est la
première fois que j'allume et le four
bah oui non plus et où je pas cyril
lignac
c'est cyril hanouna la tunisie bien sûr
sérignac c'est ça reste un beau gosse
qui fait durer la cuisine je suis un
charlot moins bon alors non 180° c paie
donc ensuite battait le jaune d'oeuf
dans un bol avec une fourchette
badie gse zone et va dit josé zone et
badigeonnez mali journée à mais on aime
ça sera après ce sera très bon alors
déjà ce qu'il faut faire
je prends les champignons les jeannettes
va lui met le feu à la scène un bordel
alors joly j'essayais de la lumière
avant ah ouais là des gestes
donc voilà j'ai réussi apparemment
allumer le feu il était tout seul je
crois qu'il faut jouer et mettre un peu
de chez met un peu de jeu mais les choux
et les champignons dont voilà voilà
comme ça je vais mettre un petit peu de
persil dans la com ça va oui lâche en
métro j'aime pas trop le persil voilà
aulas les shows de la super ok ils sont
de t'accueillir oh oui oh oui marie
jeanne oh oui
marie-jeanne regarde comme un show
médaille je mets un petit peu d'ail pour
faire recette toronto ce champignon oui
oui j'aimais mettre un peu de sel les
pubs
voilà c'est bien ça mais voilà on met un
peu de sel et poivre
je vais vous faire une chance si vous
nous rejoignez une tourte aux
champignons voilà voilà
mais là et où se mettre j'aime être
censuré mais çe footeux g foot chez
[ __ ] j'écoute un peu d'eau je crois
être la crème fraîche tient avec la
crème fraîche tient parce qu'il savait
que tu montes ya un truc à la crème
fraîche on y va on y vend des parts qui
y voit la regarde et qu'on prêche voilà
j'en mets là moi j'aime bien je suis un
amateur de crème fraîche jeune tout ce
qui effraie moi j'aime tout ce qui est
vital au poisson frais les le poulet
frais
voilà la crème fraîche voilà donc la
ensuite je fais riesch all et
j'entendais quand ça arrive seulement ça
arrive ça et là normalement quand je
fais une touche opinion je chante de
michel saad brûlé au bo d'élan
de pierre un peu ou tour des lacs salés
rebond la jeunesse rissoler la rio pas
là en fait là ce que geslin c'est que cg
ce que je vais mettre dans la tourte là
je prends ma première tour tu passais la
base de la tour tu sais les fondations
de la maison dernier attention à pas et
qui a un jeu blanc et mer permet aussi
mis ça dans le micro à lire à limoges ça
c'est mon les trahir un croc en jambe
bon voilà donc là je mets la première
partie de la tourbe et là je fais ce
qu'on appelle une une bordi sûr c'est à
dire je mets les bords de la droite sur
la sur la pâte sur le bail de trucs pour
éviter les maux redit les moisissures ce
qu'on appelle une bordure
voilà donc après qu'est-ce que je fais
ça ça y est ça c'est bon ça ça ça y est
c'est bon ça ça ça va être bon voilà
donc la voie la i-miev est en dessous
voilà c'est bon voilà bah quoi je prends
salle à turin et là je mets ça dans la
voiture et je mets tout ce qui est bon
là dedans ça c'est bon pour le moral
un petit coup pour balancer une caresse
pour décoller voilà donc pas je mets ça
là dedans voilà donc là une fois que les
champignons et tout le toutim est bien
cuit comme des oeufs dans une dans un
nid dans un nid de perdrix par exemple
bien entendu pour ceux qui connaissent
un petit peu voilà la perdrix du sud est
bon donc là mais pousse toi toi voilà
donc là je mets ça la voilà soulagés
talent là là j'ai tout donné tout ce qui
va se retrouver à l'intérieur et je dis
bien à l'intérieur de la quiche là
j'essaie de faire ça nombre et après
qu'est ce que je vais faire
eh ben je vais vous dire c'est tout con
je vais recouvert alors je vais mettre
le jaune d'oeuf
je met le jaune d'oeuf voilà eh bien ça
ça c'est bien ça tu voyais là voilà
c'est comme ça ça c'est bien tu vois
toujours mettre un petit jaune d'oeuf et
ivana et tuent tout il vacille et tuent
tout y est tu tout y est tu tout y est
tu tournes ratatouille et utile
ratatouille et une ratatouille et tuent
tout y est surtout draka taulier du tout
et ratatouille et surtout une
ratatouille et yeux tout y est tu
trouves et tutoie et tutoriels tout il
ratatouille et tuent tout il ratatouille
et surtout il rata drouille voilà bon
c'est bon ça va être très très bien tout
ça ça va être très chaud c'est pas qui
va manger ça mais bon les mecs qui va
pas partir en courant la virus là il va
partir dans un autre délire s convient
assez bien avec magna qui va bouffer ça
voilà voilà voilà c'est l'âge et le
couvercle lâché le couvercle c'était moi
bon allez suffit les conneries non
voilà la somme et ça comme ça là tu vois
je fais comme ça là tu vois tu vas tu
fais comme ça là parce que je joins les
deux pattes
c'est à dire que les deux pattes je les
joints je l'aimé comme ça comme des
joints de des joints de culasse
je fais ce qu'on appelle des dépeint des
pains azymes n'est pas à nîmes
asimo lot voilà donc là n'a rien dit là
je fais la base de la tourte mali bnda
courte
qu'est ce qui lie bell dot à courte
aulas pourtant on la tourte est belle
c'est une tourterelle merci donc voilà
on se fait ça là et après quand votre
tour tu es magnifique comme la mienne
voilà qu'est ce que je fais je peux
m'amuser à faire des petits dessins
voilà comme ça quoi et bien pas avec ça
que j'ai parlé d'identité
j'ai fait rixe à l'indien tu vois tu
fais toi moi je voulais faire un bateau
quoi bon la gelée par owen je vais faire
des points on va faire une quiche au
coin voila voila c'est bien voilà et
après et ma mère je sais pourquoi cet
effet joe 2 9
mais non c'était pour mettre dessus
comme un conte [ __ ] bref pour embellir
voilà ça ça embellit ça veut dire que tu
as klich elle était chaud c'est à dire
c'était hanouna tu vois par exemple et
tu mets ça ça devient m pokora
tu vois tu vois là c'est ça quand tu
vois là là tu vois tu l'embellie tu vois
voilà c'est la laddh c'est la quiche m
dos chorale c'est la quiche mp la voilà
laisse donne on ne nous laisse un peu
contre ma pole est à quiche contre macky
ch
alors c'est pas une petit chien
d'ailleurs pas de conneries c'est le
tour bon voilà maintenant que tout ça
est fait voilà alors je sais pas comment
avec ça on variés à ça mais bon donc ça
je peux le mettre au four permettre aux
forces armées va dit on y va
c'est parti allez on fout ça au four ces
chaussettes merde
voilà je bous de maïs les cherry hill et
18h08 on a fini à recettes ont réalisé
la quiche jusqu'à 18h40 15 20 20 15
minutes heure vingt vous avez la
découvrir dans un instant merci et
laurence ça me touche je vous le dis ça
me touche d'abord touche énormément
les chéris question corona on a john qui
dit le virus peut tamer zhu pets j'ai
oublié la quiche d'abord regardé mcnish
qui a regardé alors regardez ce que je
devais faire du roman très regardé ce
que je devais faire
voilà ce que je devais faire voilà je
devais arriver à ça voilà voilà
et ma tour tu sais ça c'est chaud cette
merde regarde voilà voilà voilà donc je
vais l'ouvrir thaler 1 voilà et je vais
vous montrer parce que là c'est très
chaud bon c'est ça rien à voir mais ça
ça a pas l'air si mal on vous dit ça a
pas l'air si mal
vous avez ce que le père je vais sortir
après je vais la donner un voisin